[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DORINA ARELLANO: Hi.
EG DAILY: Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Welcome to Google.
EG DAILY: Thanks.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Thanks for being here.
EG DAILY: It's nice to be here.
DORINA ARELLANO: So I wanted
to start with your earlier
acting career.
You were a part of a few
quite iconic cult hit movies
that became cult hits later on.
And you know, you
got "Valley Girl"
and one of my
personal favorites,
"Pee-wee's Big Adventure."
EG DAILY: Dottie.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes, Dottie.
So I wanted to ask if
you had any fond memories
from those experiences
that you wanted to share.
And did you expect these movies
to become, you know, this big?
EG DAILY: Good question.
You know, honestly, every
time I would get a project,
I never knew what was going
to happen with it, never.
Like "Pee-wee's Big Adventure"
was just a casting I went out
for and then booked it.
And all I remember
was I remember seeing
them talking about Tim Burton.
And they were saying, oh, Tim's
going to be this big director.
And I remember watching
him thinking, hm.
He's like a mad
scientist genius.
And I remember walking on
the set of "Pee-wee's Big
Adventure," and there was
all the cool like kitchen,
the cooking things, and the set.
And I remember how
detailed Tim Burton was.
And I remember thinking, he's
got something really special.
And those are the kind of
things that I take in a lot
when I'm working, is the
people I'm working with.
And a lot of the projects I
did, they would always say--
I did this movie with Kevin
Costner called "Fandango,"
and it was right when
Kevin Costner was just
starting to break his career.
And they were saying, this
guy's going to blow up.
And I always remember
wondering, like, I
wonder how they know, like how
they knew that Tim Burton was
going to blow up and how they
knew that Kevin Costner was
going to blow up.
But those are the kind of things
I remember on my projects.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's awesome.
And how did you transition
from that into voice acting?
EG DAILY: Well, I did a lot of
voices when I was a little kid.
You know, I would just like
walk around the playground
and be like (IN
HIGH VOICE) I don't
like that very much.
(REGULAR VOICE) You know,
I would just do
these weird voices.
And (DIFFERENT VOICE)
let's go beat up
Farsheed at the water fountain.
You know, we would do
voices when I was little.
But I didn't think
anything of it,
then I did a play where I
had to be a female wrestler.
In each round of the play,
I was a different age.
And then some guy had heard
me do voices in this play,
and he was like, you're
really good with your voice.
And I never thought
anything about it,
but it was just this thing that
I never thought anything about.
And he said, you should
audition for some things.
And so it was one of
those things that just
kind of dropped into my life.
And I went out for this
one audition for a cartoon,
and it was to do the voice
for this little character.
And I was like, hm.
That sort of sounds
like the voice
I've been doing my whole life
since I was a little girl.
And this character had like big
floppy lips and a round head,
and so I just sort of started
doing (IN TOMMY PICKLES' VOICE)
oh, you know, Chuckie,
I'm not sure I like that.
(REGULAR VOICE) And then
I auditioned for that,
and then I booked Tommy Pickles.
I don't remember what your
question was originally,
but that's where I landed.
DORINA ARELLANO: No, yeah.
I actually was just
about to ask you about--
EG DAILY: I read
your mind, yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: --the
legendary Tommy Pickles.
So I'm assuming some
of you here, like me,
grew up in the '90s and
were Nickelodeon fans.
And I love "Rugrats."
EG DAILY: Yay.
DORINA ARELLANO: It
was very, very cool.
I hear there is a
reboot coming back.
EG DAILY: Yeah.
There's been a reboot--
a feature film and, I
think, 26 new episodes,
which should be amazing.
I can't say more than that,
but I'm really excited.
DORINA ARELLANO: But you're
going to be on it, right?
EG DAILY: Well, I can't
say more than that.
But I would say that I'm really
excited about it, you know.
"Rugrats" is a family.
It's a family that
we grew up at.
And I always think,
like, everybody
wants to feel cozy and
safe, like especially today.
It's raining.
But everyone wants to
feel a cozy safety,
and I really think like
"Rugrats" brought that family
thing to people's homes.
And that's why everybody loves
it, because the moms loved it,
the dads loved it,
the kids loved it,
and now the generations
are loving it
because it was family.
It was like this cozy
thing, and for them
to bring back their family,
people are really excited.
Like, I get to be cozy
again in the family.
Yeah, it's good.
DORINA ARELLANO: Bringing
happiness to lots of people.
So how did you come
up with the voice?
Did you have some
form of direction
from the people working on it?
Did you just kind of
start playing around, or--
EG DAILY: You know, like
I said, the audition was
my first audition I'd ever
been on for an animated show.
And I had done
movies my whole life
and I had done
singing my whole life.
So I knew how to
play with my voice,
but when they showed me this
claymation, I just was like--
I think that's what my god gift
is, my ability to see a mouth
and know what sound is going
to come out of that mouth.
And I always tell everyone,
like if I were to put all of you
guys in a row and then you
were to play me all your guys'
voices all over the
place, like not in order,
that I would probably be
able to pick the voice that
goes with the mouth.
And I think that's
what my weird--
it's a very strange gift.
Like, it's really strange.
But I think my first
instinct on Tommy Pickles
when I saw the little claymation
was (IN TOMMY PICKLES' VOICE)
I'm not sure I really like--
(REGULAR VOICE) you know,
he was so kind of innocent
and sweet and very much baby.
And that was the
first voice that
came out of my mouth and
my first voice audition
ever for a cartoon, and
then I just booked it.
And I didn't know
what I was doing.
It was not in my
wheelhouse to do animation.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's great.
So I saw a video of
you giving voice tips,
like voice acting
tips, and there
was a really cool thing that she
did for like teeth chattering.
I guess you put like a
pen between your teeth?
EG DAILY: A pen or a pencil.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
EG DAILY: I wish you
had a pen or pencil.
DORINA ARELLANO: Do
you guys have a pen?
EG DAILY: If anybody
has a pencil--
DORINA ARELLANO: Do you have
any other tips like that
that you use or that you
think are fun, for people
that want to get into it?
EG DAILY: Yeah.
Well, first of all, I do
have a voiceover seminar
that I did for a live audience,
and it's a digital download
on EGDaily.com.
And I did that because a
lot of people were asking,
do you have any tips and tools
for voiceover, and, you know,
the basics and stuff.
But there's so many weird tools.
Like, if you go to
a voice session,
you'll see people do things
like [BLUBBERING SOUND]..
You know, they pull their
lip out or they mess
with their cheek.
Or you know, SpongeBob
does [CHOPPY VOICE]..
That's how he gets that sound.
I can't do it that fast,
but he does it really fast.
[CHOPPY VOICE] There it is.
Anyway, that's SpongeBob.
Don't tell him I
told you the secret.
And the pencil
teeth chattering is
you basically just
take a pencil or a pen
and you put in your teeth
and you just go like this.
And it makes a
[IMITATING CHATTERING TEETH],,
like a shivering
cold cartoon sound.
I mean, there's a
million tips like that.
There's like, (IN
BRITISH ACCENT)
if you're doing a British
accent, you talk like this.
And then if you leave your
tongue (IN INDIAN ACCENT)
on the tip of your mouth, you
start to talk a little bit more
on the Indian side.
It sort of brings out
the Indian inside of--
(REGULAR VOICE) I'm not doing
very well myself right now,
but there's so many
little tools and tips.
And a lot of the time, it's
playing with your mouth.
You know, to create braces,
you might put your finger
in your mouth (IN LISPY VOICE)
and sort of talk like this.
So Susie has braces and
she spits all over herself.
(REGULAR VOICE) You know,
so that's a kid with braces,
and there's a lot of tips.
And it's not very sexy, but
it's what I get paid for.
DORINA ARELLANO: It may not look
sexy, but it sounds awesome.
EG DAILY: I feel sexy.
DORINA ARELLANO: So I would
like to talk about the t-shirt
that I'm wearing.
EG DAILY: (IN BUTTERCUP'S VOICE)
Yeah, I love your t-shirt,
but I just have one question.
Why is Buttercup on the bottom?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yes.
We're good here, you guys.
That was great.
I'm very happy now.
So Buttercup was my favorite.
I grew up as a very
feisty teenager,
and I related to this
kindergarten girl.
So out of the three, she was
obviously the feistiest one.
What has it been like to
be part of a show that
has inspired so many
girls to kind of find
their power and their voice.
And has she also been kind of an
outlet for stress or rage when
you're--
EG DAILY: (IN BUTTERCUP'S
VOICE) Yes, she is.
(REGULAR VOICE)
Buttercup is like--
I think of the three, she's
the feistiest, obviously.
And I just think there's
nothing cooler than little tiny,
petite little girls
with superpowers,
and superpowers to
save the day or help
people that are not doing well.
And I love that it takes
away that you have to be huge
or you have to be super
muscular, you know,
that wanting to make the world
better is The Powerpuff Girls.
And they're little,
and they're petite,
and they're little girls,
but they still are all
about making the planet better.
So what an incredible message
for everyone right now.
You know, especially
now when things
have changed so much like with
the MeToo movement and stuff.
I just think it's really
incredible to have.
And the other thing
I always say I
love about The Powerpuff Girls
is that they work as a team.
And I really think that--
I know my life goes better
when I work as a team.
I try not to make a lot of
decisions without my tribe.
And The Powerpuff Girls
are so good because they're
so different and they
work together as a team.
So I just think the
whole message is just
awesome-- little, cute girls.
And they're cute,
and they're feisty.
It's awesome.
DORINA ARELLANO:
And the show itself
is not just funny and great,
but it's very artistic.
You know, you worked
with, obviously,
other great voice actors like
Tara Strong and Tom Kane.
Like, is there
somebody that you've
collaborated with in
your career that you're
like, that was a great memory.
I love that.
And then is there somebody
you're actually hoping
to work with in the future?
EG DAILY: I mean, the really
cool thing about animation
is you'll show up at
a voiceover session
and you'll work with
like Phyllis Diller.
You know?
Yeah, Phyllis Diller.
We were just talking
about "Star Wars."
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh, Mark--
EG DAILY: Mark Hamill.
Like, you'll walk into
a session and there
will be like legendary people.
Like Phyllis Diller
was like, ha ha!
Crazy, but I liked her.
And she was probably 90 then,
and just amazingly talented.
So you never know
with voiceover,
but that's what's so cool about
it is it doesn't have anything
to do with your body or your
age or your face or your hair
or your color or your race
or your religion or your sex.
And you know, I play a boy.
I play a girl.
I play an old lady.
I play a teenager.
You know, I love the people
that come in and do animation,
and I love the people that
I get to be in animation.
DORINA ARELLANO: And speaking
of just the differences
between voice acting
and on-camera acting,
are there some
challenges or things
that you consider fun, more
from like one or the other?
EG DAILY: Yeah.
I think what's cool
about on-camera
is I'm a character actress,
so I like to really
like transform my body.
And I get a lot of roles
where I get to change--
like Sex-Head in "31."
Did any of you guys see that?
DORINA ARELLANO: Horror fans?
EG DAILY: Horror fans in here?
(IN BUTTERCUP'S VOICE)
What's wrong with you guys?
(REGULAR VOICE)
I'm just kidding.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah,
you work with Rob Zombie
in a couple of movies, right?
With "31" and "Devil's Rejects."
EG DAILY: Yeah.
Well usually, Rob-- the
good thing about Rob Zombie
is he casts very
specifically and he usually
knows exactly how he
wants to wardrobe you
before you show up on the set.
Like he knows my
size and my body,
so he always puts me in
very particular-- so for me,
I really love transforming
physically for on-camera.
And you know, Dottie
was kind of quirky.
She was quirky.
And then I love--
the beauty of bad
animation is that it
has nothing to do with
your body, and you know,
it has nothing.
So you're so much,
even more freer,
because you could be
an inanimate object.
You could be a talking
puppy or a ball,
or you could be talking
that, whatever this thing is.
DORINA ARELLANO:
You were Chairry
in "Pee-wee's Playhouse" too.
EG DAILY: No, I wasn't actually.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Oh, you weren't.
OK.
EG DAILY: No.
I didn't do
"Pee-wee's Playhouse."
I just did "Pee-wee's
Big Adventure."
DORINA ARELLANO:
Just "Adventure," OK.
EG DAILY: Yeah.
But yeah, so the
difference is just--
they're both amazing.
One, I get to transform
myself and my body.
The other, I get to use my voice
to transform myself anywhere,
you know.
And sometimes I
really like being
like on a set where I get to
be all dressed differently
and change myself
up, or sometimes I
like being in my pajamas
in a recording studio,
and then I can do
whatever I want to.
DORINA ARELLANO: And you
are not just an actress.
You're a musician as well.
EG DAILY: Yeah, I'm a musician.
DORINA ARELLANO: And for
'80s fans especially,
you were part of a
lot of soundtracks.
You did like "Better Off
Dead," "The Breakfast Club,"
"'Scarface."
Like, there's so many
things in your resume.
What was that like?
Did you write those songs?
What was that experience like?
EG DAILY: Some of
those songs I wrote,
and some of those songs, they--
I would be in a studio
working on some soundtrack
for some movie, and
then some huge producer
on some other big movie
would walk in the studio.
And he'd be like, who's
singing that song?
Who's singing that?
And I'd be like, it's me.
And then they'd be
like, oh, can you
co-write with
Harold Faltermeyer,
the guy who did that, dun dun
dun-dun-dun dun dun, "Axel F"
theme song?
So they'd be like, can you work
on a song for our soundtrack?
So then, the next
thing you know,
I'd be writing and
singing the theme song
for "Thief of Hearts."
And that was just a weird thing.
I mean, my thing is I love
music and I love writing music,
and music has like
really run my life.
Like, I just feel
like it changes my--
it just rocks my world.
Music rocks my world.
Like, it changes everything.
Like, I could be
talking to you right now
and playing this
one kind of music
and then I see you one way,
playing another kind of music,
I see you another way.
So to me, it was always my
deep, deep passion to do music.
And I don't know.
Whenever I did a
movie, I'd be like, oh.
I think I have a
song for this movie.
For "Rugrats," I'd be
like, I have the song.
It's called "Changing Faces."
And the next thing you know,
I'd get it in that movie.
Music just started to--
it all just sort of fall on top
of each other-- music and then
a movie and then an acting
and then a voice thing.
And you know, so like
I never get bored.
DORINA ARELLANO: Apparently.
EG DAILY: And I'm a mom too.
DORINA ARELLANO: And
apparently, you do it all too.
EG DAILY: Yeah, I kind of do.
I think I'd be bored if I
didn't keep changing it up.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
That makes sense.
So speaking of music,
you recently wrote a song
and also made a music video for
this song called "So Pretty."
So I want to talk about
what I'm kind of hearing is
called the So Pretty movement.
And it basically,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it kind of
talks about how it's
great to want to look
good on the outside,
but it's more important to
look within and be beautiful
inside and kind.
And can you talk about that?
EG DAILY: Yeah.
So the So Pretty
movement came because I'm
a mom of two really beautiful
millennial young women.
And I guess because
my career was always
based on-- luckily, I
got into voiceover so I
had some relief from it, but
my whole career was based
on how I looked and
my size and my weight
and my face and my skin.
You know, there was so much
importance on the outside
that I suffered a lot.
I mean, I went through all those
phases of like eating disorders
and really battled.
Like, I wanted to be good
on the outside all the time.
And then what happens
is I become a mother,
and then I have to be
responsible for my kids.
So my girls are like typical
girls, and they'll be like,
do I look fat?
Do I look fat?
And it's like, oh, my
god, because I did that,
but I had to change it.
I had to change it
up and my practice
was not to say anything
about their body
and say, how do you feel?
You know, how are you feeling?
And they'd be like, I don't
know but do I look fat?
And I'm like, no.
How do you feel?
And my daughter would start
crying and say, I feel sad.
And so I think what happened
is the "So Pretty" song
came about as I was
writing a bunch of songs
for some new things, and I wrote
with these two new writers,
Elliott and Elijah.
And this song came out, and
it was called "So Pretty,"
and it was all about that thing.
And I felt like it
was so channeled,
because the song happened
in like-- we wrote it
from top to bottom in
like 30 minutes, lyrics,
everything was done.
And when we got done writing
it, I left the session that day,
and I was like, I have
to release that song.
And they were
like, well, we were
going to submit it
for this other artist.
And I was like, I have to
release that song because it
matters so much to me.
And the song was about--
you know, especially now
there's the Kardashians,
and they're
beautiful, and they do
a lot in the realm
of like fashion,
and they're very fashion
forward, and you learn a lot.
But there's also
a lot of things.
There's a lot of
augmentation that goes on,
and that's dangerous.
And I actually have
friends that have
done things that are so
dangerous to their bodies
and their faces that--
you know, there's one
woman in the video.
You'll see the video.
I won't tell you who
she is, but there's
one woman that almost
lost her life because she
had her boobs done so
many times and her body
lipoed so many times that
she end up getting staph.
And then they had to put like
a PICC line into her heart
so the staph wouldn't
go to her brain.
I mean, it's really scary stuff.
But to me, I thought it was
really important to make sure
that if you're
feeling like you have
to do that much stuff
on your outsides,
well then you better do that
much stuff on your insides
to fill yourself up,
because somewhere,
there's a hole leaking.
And that means like--
I know for myself too.
I'm going like, oh, my god.
I'm getting so wrinkly.
Oh, my god.
My neck is dropping.
And it's like, then I say,
what's really going on here?
Like, where am I feeling empty?
Where am I not getting
the attention I need
or the love that I need?
So that's what "So
Pretty" is all about.
It's all about going deeper.
You know, fixing the
outsides is a bottomless pit.
For men and women,
it's a bottomless pit.
You can work on
yourself like crazy,
but the work has to
start from the inside,
and you have to love
yourself on the inside.
And you have to ask
yourself, do I like myself?
Am I being a kind person?
Am I being an evolving person?
And so that's what the So
Pretty movement is about,
and the song is basically that.
And there's a lot
of versions I've
been releasing like on
Instagram, some B-track
versions, short
clips of where I did
some even funny versions
and some campy versions
of the same message.
So check those out as well.
But this is the
"So Pretty" video.
Did you want to--
DORINA ARELLANO:
That's super cool.
No, I saw it.
Yeah, no.
It's great.
And we'll watch it here
before audience questions.
So thank you for doing
something like that.
That's very important
and very cool.
And you also are very much
involved in animal activism.
So I want to talk about that
because animals are awesome.
And so, do you have
any organizations
that you think people should
be aware of or support,
or how can people help?
EG DAILY: Well,
there's a million,
and that's why I like
to use my voice for--
that's one of the
biggest places I
like to use my voice,
other than animation,
but to speak for the
ones that can't speak.
So there's like Last
Chance for Animals.
They do the most
incredible animal activism
work you will ever see.
I mean, Chris
DeRose, who runs it,
has been shot saving animals
from cruel and horrible animal
abuse all over the world in
different spectrums of animal
abuse.
So that's one of the main ones
that I do a lot of work for.
And there's also smaller ones
like Tobie's Small Dog Rescue.
If you go to Instagram, look
up Tobie's Small Dog Rescue.
And that just
happens to be a woman
I met who just has this huge
heart, and goes to shelters
and rescues a lot of little
dogs that the owners just
didn't take care of.
And they were dying
of something or they
were suffering from something,
and they basically just say,
we don't want it anymore.
And the dogs are in the pound
like, where's my family?
You know, they're so sad
and it's so sad to me.
But this one woman, Tee from
Tobie's Small Dog Rescue,
goes and pulls them
from these shelters.
And they're a mess,
and then what I do
is I foster some of these.
A lot of these little
dogs, I bring home.
And some of them
are so-- like, one
was thrown out of a car
window, a moving car window.
Tiny dog, on its head.
And somebody saw it and
thought the dog was dead,
and then rescued it.
And then the dog was like
falling over for a while
because it had head trauma.
And then I take that dog, and
I just hold it on my chest
and love it until
it feels safe again.
And it takes them a
long time sometimes.
So there's so many things.
There's so many things you
could do, little or small,
for animals.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO:
That was so great.
So I wanted to play
a little game--
EG DAILY: OK.
I like games.
DORINA ARELLANO: --because
you're very talented.
So I wanted to come
up with some questions
that you could answer in
your legendary voices.
EG DAILY: Awesome, OK.
I'm going to take this off by
I feel nervous a little bit.
OK.
DORINA ARELLANO: What are
some of your favorite movies?
EG DAILY: (IN TOMMY PICKLES'
VOICE) Let me see here.
I really like "Babe"
even though I'm not
doing Babe's voice right now.
And I don't just like it
because I did the voice of Babe.
(REGULAR VOICE) I also liked
(IN HIGHER VOICE) "Happy Feet."
(REGULAR VOICE) As
far as on-camera,
(IN BUTTERCUP'S VOICE) I
really like "This is 40."
You know the movie, "This
is 40." (REGULAR VOICE)
Is that what it's called?
(IN BUTTERCUP'S
VOICE) Going on 40?
I really like that movie
because it was really accurate.
(REGULAR VOICE) Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO:
That was so good.
What do you Google the most?
EG DAILY: Animal rescue videos.
People think I'm crazy.
I'm always like
[IMITATING CRYING],, you know,
watching these videos, crying
because they're so remarkable.
These dogs are so forgiving.
So that's my main thing I
think I watch, animal videos.
And then I watch
autobiographies because I
like learning about
people's journeys,
especially people
that have had like--
most of the time, if anybody's
got a really cool career,
they've had some rough times.
Because usually,
you go through life,
and you have these
journeys where
you have like all kinds
of stuff happen to you,
and then you're able to be a
messenger for such cool stuff.
So I like messages and
I like learning them
and I like teaching them
and I like videos with them.
DORINA ARELLANO: OK, cool.
I got another game
question for you.
EG DAILY: Google is
the bomb, by the way.
Right? (IN HIGHER
VOICE) I love Google!
DORINA ARELLANO: Can you answer
as Buttercup, what music do you
listen to?
EG DAILY: (IN BUTTERCUP'S
VOICE) Well, I really
like bands like Coldplay.
Adam Levine does
some good songs.
Let me think here.
What's your favorites?
DORINA ARELLANO: My favorite?
Oh, that's a lot.
Everything from the
Beatles to Mozart
to Billie Ellish, everyone.
EG DAILY: Billie Ellish.
I really like her too.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
She's really cool.
You guys, Buttercup is
talking to me right now.
I'm kind of freaking out.
EG DAILY: Don't freak out.
Just calm down.
DORINA ARELLANO: In a good way,
freaking out in a good way.
EG DAILY: I mean, there's really
just so many different kinds
of artists I like.
I actually like
Justin Bieber too.
I like some of his songs too.
DORINA ARELLANO: Buttercup's
into Justin Bieber.
EG DAILY: Even
though he's a brat.
He's kind of a brat like me.
Yeah.
Is he really married?
DORINA ARELLANO: I think so.
That's what the Instagrams say.
EG DAILY: Dang it!
No, I'm just kidding.
DORINA ARELLANO: So,
EG, what would you
be doing if you weren't
an actress or musician?
EG DAILY: I think I'd be a
veterinarian or a paramedic.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: Trying to help
people and animals as well.
EG DAILY: I think so.
I just have a thing.
I just have a thing
about healing people.
That would be my superpower
if I was a real superhero
with a superpower.
That would be my superpower
I'd want, is the power to heal.
DORINA ARELLANO: To heal?
That's a good one.
And then we're going to open
the floor to audience questions,
so please think
of some good ones.
AUDIENCE: I am curious.
You know, throughout your
experience in entertainment,
in this industry, was there
either a mistake you made
or a really
challenging event that
might have occurred to you
that you're so glad happened?
EG DAILY: I mean,
there were a couple
of those times in
my career where
I felt like I made
a bad decision,
where like I turned
down something
that, once I turned
it down, afterward,
I was like, oh, my god.
What did I do that for?
And I battled myself for
years on certain decisions.
Like if I had made
this better decision,
then I would have
been there probably.
But I really think
that everything really
does happen the way
it's supposed to,
and I think because I've
really applied myself
to learning that everything
happens for a reason,
like everything.
And then there was a time where
I went through a lot of anxiety
and had like a midlife crisis
of like severe anxiety.
And I didn't know what that was.
I was like, what is anxiety?
Like, I thought something
was really wrong.
I was like, I'm--
can I say fucked up?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
EG DAILY: I thought
I was fucked up.
I was like, am I ever
going to be normal.
I literally was like, what
is happening to my body?
And then at the moment,
I was just like,
I don't know how people survive
feeling that kind of anxiety
in their body.
And I did a lot of
learning about it.
I studied a lot and I went in.
And it was a scary time.
People were like,
what's wrong with you?
You're not yourself.
And I'm like, I'm not myself.
I don't know who this
person is, but it's not me.
You know, and then that
time period actually
forced me to do the kind of
work that changed my life,
and the kind of work that
made me have so much more
compassion for
everybody that is going
through any kind of thing,
and the kind of work that
made me have a lot more
humility and more gratitude
for everything.
So I would say that's a
really great question.
And I think that if people
are going through a dark time,
that's a really incredible time.
And know that, around
the bend, is some magic.
And I think when you're
feeling that dark,
it just means that you have to--
when you're in a
real darkness, it
forces you to take certain steps
to find back to a lit-up path
again.
And that just means you're
going to do a little more work.
And it's pretty
incredible what happens
on the other side of that.
So I would say yeah.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Thank you for sharing.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Did you say that
when you auditioned for Tommy
Pickles that it was claymation?
Did I hear you correctly?
EG DAILY: Yeah.
They actually showed
me a claymation
of Tommy Pickles when I
first auditioned for it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
That's fascinating.
So "Rugrats," like in the
pilot, it was claymation?
How did they make
that transition?
EG DAILY: No.
I think they actually did a
claymation for the animators
so they could see the real
full spectrum of the character.
But to be honest
about Tommy Pickles
was I actually wasn't
the first Tommy Pickles.
I don't know if
anybody knows that,
but they actually had
cast someone else.
They had done a whole
season worth of the show
before they aired it,
and then they, I guess,
wanted to change the voice.
So I came in afterward
and had to re-dub all
of the episodes they had done.
But I think the
claymation was just
a way to show what the
character looked in three--
you know, in the palm of
your hand and not just
a two-dimensional or you know--
AUDIENCE: Wow.
Very cool.
DORINA ARELLANO: Over here.
EG DAILY: I get so nervous
when you throw that thing.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
is there any voice
that you've done that
you found especially
difficult to do or to keep up?
EG DAILY: Yes.
One was the voice of--
you know the live action,
the "Little Rascals" feature?
DORINA ARELLANO: Oh, yeah.
EG DAILY: Yeah.
So they did the live
action, and then the boy
that did that voice, they
needed it to be scratchier.
So he was like (IN SCRATCHY
VOICE) what the [INAUDIBLE]..
(REGULAR VOICE) You
know, they wanted this.
And I was like, OK, here
goes, which was really
ripping for your throat.
But it was only little batches
of Froggy in that movie,
but I did that and that
was a tough voice to do.
And also, there
was a movie called
"Lorenzo's Oil"
that was, I think,
Susan Sarandon and Nick Nolte?
Susan Sarandon, and I can't
remember the other actor.
But it was a really
cool movie, live action,
about a boy who was ill.
And then as he started
to deteriorate,
he couldn't do the
acting it required
because he was so little.
So then they
brought me in, which
happened to be the same director
I did "Babe 1" and "Babe
2" and "Happy Feet"
for, George Miller,
who did all the Mad Max movies.
And so they brought
me in on that.
That was the first one I
worked on with George Miller.
And that movie, they had to
lie me in a giant soundstage.
There was a giant
screen back here.
And they lied me on the ground
and they put a mic over me
while I lied down.
And the director
would be on his knees,
and be like pressing on
my ribs and my chest.
Or I'd be standing
in front of him
and he'd be like squeezing
my ribs like that,
and that was tough too.
So I'd have to be like
[DEMONSTRATING STRUGGLING
VOICE].
It was like that.
And that is how fancy
and sexy you can be.
Yeah.
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
Going off of that
question, actually,
have you ever actually like lost
your voice just from working?
EG DAILY: I have a
really strong voice,
I think, from doing
so much singing.
But there were times where--
it's pretty rare.
I mean, I usually can push
myself right through it.
So let's say I'm
here, and I actually
am getting over a little cold.
But, and then (IN HIGHER VOICE)
if I need to go right here,
I just kind of push it over it.
I sort of push it
right over the cold.
You put sort of
energy behind it so
that I'm able to like,
(IN ELDERLY VOICE)
if I want to talk like an old
lady who says, honey, why don't
you come over some time?
You know, I just kind of
push past the voice a little
bit into another place.
There's been a few times
where I had some kind of cold.
It's very rare that I can't push
past it, where I lost my voice
and I like had to
push the session back.
But yeah, not that often.
DORINA ARELLANO: That's awesome.
I just love how you can
just transition immediately
into any voices.
It's very, very incredible.
EG DAILY: It's fun.
It's fun especially when there
are telemarketers calling you.
It really is.
And then you're like
(IN CHILDISH VOICE)
my mom's not here right now.
Can she call you later?
Can we have your number,
and we'll call you
at your dinnertime too?
And they're like
[IMITATING PANIC]
DORINA ARELLANO: Can I hire
you to do that for [INAUDIBLE]??
EG DAILY: Absolutely.
DORINA ARELLANO: Next
question back there.
AUDIENCE: All right,
another "Rugrats" question.
You spoke fondly of the
show because a lot of it
was about family and
everyone can relate to it.
So it was funny
and fun to watch,
but like a lot of good shows,
there's so much more to it.
There's a lot of lessons,
especially for kid viewers.
So it was about friendship,
forgiveness, disappointment,
everything.
Was there any episode or moment
in the show that you remember
being particularly proud of?
EG DAILY: I think, overall,
with "Rugrats," I loved them--
I mean, I learned a
lot from "Rugrats."
I loved them teaching us about--
you know, when they
did like the Passover
episodes and the different
religious holidays
and really embracing all that.
And I think it was,
in general, I just
loved that they brought up
all kinds of subject matter--
single parenting,
and the feelings
that a child goes through
where they only have one
parent, and the loss of that.
And for me, I just really liked
where they got a little deep.
And I kind of like deep.
I like deep sometimes.
But I think those were the ones.
I mean, particularly, if I were
to really look at episodes,
I really love the naked episode
where Tommy talks about being--
(IN TOMMY PICKLES' VOICE)
I like being nakey!
(REGULAR VOICE)
You know, I mean,
who doesn't like being nakey,
and just the feelings of just
that--
you know.
I think I really
like that episode.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
DORINA ARELLANO: Over there.
AUDIENCE: So I want
to start off by saying
thank you for being one of
the voices of my childhood.
EG DAILY: Yeah.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I very
much appreciate it.
But I have a question about
your creative process.
So when you are trying
to voice a character
like a human
character, you say you
can match someone's
mouth with the voice they
should be making.
But when someone says,
OK, we brought you here
to be the voice of this
talking bridge, what
goes through your
mind to say, this
is exactly how this bridge
is supposed to sound?
EG DAILY: That's
a great question.
Well, I would look at the
bridge, and I would see,
is it a girthy bridge?
Is it a stone bridge?
Is it rickety?
I mean, I would literally
just look at all those things.
(IN DEEP VOICE) So if
was a girthy bridge,
I would bring in some depth.
(REGULAR VOICE) You know,
if it's an old bridge,
(IN ELDERLY VOICE) I might
bring in a little older bridge.
(REGULAR VOICE) You
know, I literally
would just look at the
materials that the bridge is,
and then just base it on that.
You know what I mean?
It works.
I don't know how it
works, but it works.
And usually, the first voice
that comes out of my mouth
is usually the right one.
Sometimes they might say,
OK, now do that voice, but--
like for "Rugrats,"
when they did "Rugrats,"
and then they did
"All Growed Up,"
it was (IN TOMMY PICKLES' VOICE)
Tommy Pickles talks right here.
(REGULAR VOICE) And
then they'd say,
now we're going to
do Tommy Pickles
all growed up, a
little bit older.
So then you just have to imagine
like dialing it up on a radio.
Like, (IN TOMMY PICKLES' VOICE)
Tommy Pickles talk like this,
and then they want him
to be a little bit older,
so then I keep his
voice a little cracky,
but he's sort of
like a teen boy.
You know what I mean?
So there.
That's how you do it.
It's weird, but it works.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EG DAILY: You're welcome.
DORINA ARELLANO: So good.
And going off of his question
too, I wanted to ask,
for just on-camera
acting, assuming
you use some of the
same voice skills
that you developed
because-- you know,
if you have like Candy from
"Devil's Rejects" as opposed
to like a Dottie from Pee-wee.
Right?
Like, they were all
very different voices.
Do you use the same
techniques as well?
EG DAILY: Kind of,
yeah, a little bit.
Like Rob Zombie on "31," which
is the most recent one where
I have the blue hair, you
know, he actually said to me,
I want to do something different
with this character's voice.
And I really love that
because normally directors
don't do that.
But Rob's a singer, you know.
And so I really love
that I got to make
this character a little bit
like a cartoon come to life.
Like she was wearing blue and
I had these little bloomers on.
My wardrobe came on a hanger.
Clipped to the hanger was
a little plastic baggy,
and in the plastic baggy
was two pieces of duct tape,
like two little Xs of duct
tape, and then a little--
it's so crazy.
Anyway, everything about
that character was--
she was little and she was
feisty, but she was not like--
I don't know.
There was just
something about that.
And he said, I want you to have
a particular kind of voice.
And I just said, this is
a great opportunity for me
to merge what I do.
And that's why Sex-Head
was (IN SEX-HEAD'S VOICE)
see you later, Popeye.
I'm going to go get
me some spinach.
I don't talk as sweet
as that, but she did.
DORINA ARELLANO: I
mean, it felt like I
was watching a comic book.
EG DAILY: Yeah, I love that.
That was what was
so fun about it.
DORINA ARELLANO: It was so cool.
EG DAILY: I'd like
to do more movies
like that, where I get to be
a comic book character come
to life.
Because it's so
limitless, like what
you can do with wardrobe and
makeup and hair, and you know,
it's incredible.
And then change your voice up.
I'd like to be like a
small little Gremlin thing
where I'm just like
(IN LOW SCRATCHY VOICE)
I don't really like
that very-- you know.
It's just limitless.
DORINA ARELLANO:
Gremlins 3, maybe they
should get you on there.
EG DAILY: Right?
DORINA ARELLANO: Yeah.
EG, where can people find you?
EG DAILY: You guys can find
me on Instagram and Twitter
at RealEGDaily, because
there's some fake ones.
So make sure it says "real"
before my name, EG Daily,
like daily news.
And then I'm also on Facebook.
I have a fan Facebook and a
regular, so try to find those.
And then I also have
EGDaily.com where
it has everything on there.
I mean, you can get all
my handles on there,
the correct ones.
And I think my Instagram
feed's on there.
So it's all on there.
And then my YouTube page has a
lot of music videos and things
that I put out there on YouTube.
So EG Daily on EG
Daily's YouTube page.
But keeping it
real, RealEGDaily.
That's me, yeah.
And I try to answer-- like,
people will message me.
And you know, like if you
guys have any questions
or you have a real passion
or desire to connect with me,
I really try to follow, when
I feel that from people,
to make myself accessible.
Because I've met some of the
most incredible people that--
one of my best
friends was a stalker,
and she turned out
to be my best friend.
She literally followed me at
these concerts I was doing.
And she scared me
at first, and she
would be like, I took
all these pictures of you
and here's a book.
And I was like, oh, my god.
She's a stalker.
But then over time--
DORINA ARELLANO: It
wasn't me, you guys.
EG DAILY: I was wondering
if that was you.
No, she was Spanish.
Anyway, she ended up like--
she just kept
connecting to me and I
felt her incredible
desire to be connected.
And over time, she ended
up being my assistant,
my personal assistant.
And then she became
one of my best friends,
and I was just her maid
of honor at her wedding
to her girlfriend in Hawaii.
It was amazing.
DORINA ARELLANO: What
an incredible story.
EG DAILY: Incredible.
So I try to keep myself
open for magical connections
with people.
And you know, you never know.
DORINA ARELLANO: See?
So the story is be kind, right?
That works sometimes.
EG DAILY: Be kind and
follow your desire.
If you want to meet
someone, make it happen.
People like me will allow you
to come over and hang out.
Well, I don't know
about that, but maybe.
DORINA ARELLANO: Well,
thank you so much
for such an inspiring career,
and thank you for basically,
like Matt said, being the
voice of our childhood,
and thank you for being here.
And please come back.
EG DAILY: I'm really
happy I got to be here.
Thank you, guys, so much.
[APPLAUSE]